just be living Catholicism also has some
similar claims of universality in the
Pacific global leader yes well I tend to
I don't like this particular technique
of mine but I mean it's basically to ask
there are three at the moment in the
monotheistic traditions there is a there
is LOM there is Catholicism there is
Pentecost ism I mean there are there are
lots of other things as well but I mean
these are three highly expensive forms
now the Islamic 1 i've tried to
characterize forgive me in terms of this
anti greased the integral form where
politics and religion are closely
related in territory is closely related
etc the Catholic one I believe is
halfway between the two in it has
separated itself out from the
monopolistic relationship to territory
and power its grant parties been pushed
out part is also taken itself out of
those relationships and so the Catholic
churches in between it still has a based
on relationship to territory and
incidentally that relationship to
territory is enormously important the
sense of the faith and land faith and
place our are just enormously powerful
and so one mustn't one muscle just say
no this is somehow all all kind of
backward that that's a very important
human sense faith place land territory
all those things going together and the
Catholic Church is separating itself off
and I would in terms of the theory of
function differentiation suggest that
the catholic church has moved into a
more like a voluntary organization the
sacrament of baptism incidentally is
very closely related to this because if
you have a sacrament of baptism the
baptizes
a child at birth that is birthright
membership in a particular place in the
particular territory right and
particular community the other forms
adopt adult baptism because that's a
matter of mature choice right you can
see that how the theology of baptism
actually mirrors these two very basic
Sarah Palin said I was I was first born
catholic and I'm second-born Pentecostal
that's a very interesting comment
because it it dramatizes this difference
the element of choice what question am i
answering by the way I'm just using I
just oh yes about Catholicism if so well
the Catholicism is is centralized right
I mean it's attempted it attempts to
centralization and the Vatican Council
was to it was to try and disperse the
element of power to some extent but
nevertheless it is highly centralized so
what you've got is a a centralized form
of religion which has got a very strong
sense of the communal and that that as
we were talking over lunch enables it to
offer a critique of capitalism to defend
the communal is not necessarily simply
to defend a right wing position it's
also to have to articulate a critique of
captains individualism so you can see
how what was at one point in time a
reaction a reaction actually a
reactionary position then becomes a
progressive position so you can't
characterize what the Catholic Church
will do in the Philippines it will be
behind the revolution in Spain it will
be against a revolution right it just
depends but it is the decentralized form
the fissile Multi multi cultural form
against the D central the centralized
one that is also moving bit by bit
towards a more volunteer istic for